on today's show it's an animated battle
featuring the craziest cartoon carnage
of this millennium
a world vending show centered around a
mismatched pair is taking on the
topically minded
socially unconscious adventures of four
colorado lads oh my god
i killed kenny you bastard that's right
folks rick and morty are gonna go on
down to south park
will they get to unwind or leave their
woes behind that we're gonna have
ourselves a time either way on this
episode of versus
and this humble host without temptation
will be pacing you through these five
rounds
that will determine our winner round one
tomato meter slash
audience score round two ratings
round three characters round four
iconic moments and then we'll do a wild
card round to settle the score once and
for all
or at least until next season folks this
is the verses i've been waiting for my
whole
life and not just because it's a matchup
between two of my favorite shows
any time you go to work and are not only
allowed to say
mr poopy butthole but it's an actual
requirement
you're in for a good day unless you're a
janitor i guess
clean up on aisle fun let's get it on
wait a minute
way we go my god this is even bigger
than the final battle in the lord of the
rings movie
it's like it's like 10 times bigger than
that battle round one tomato meter slash
audience score it's true these programs
are super successful
firmly lodged in the cultural zeitgeist
and have begat countless threads on
reddit
okay but when you sit down to watch
south park or rick and morty
did you like it odds say yes
both shows are fresh according to both
the tomato meter and the audience score
how fresh you ask so fresh that neither
show even had
one rotten season god damn it i love
myself until south park finally dipped
below the fresh line and into fresh
adjacent territory
when season 21 knots 54 as an average on
the tomato meter
you have to overdo it in today's society
stan you can't be nuanced and subtle
anymore else critics go
wow what was the point of that i will
say season 22 rebounded nicely with a 77
only to watch season 23 tumble back down
to 50 this is like that little greta
girl with the global warming
buzzkill all told south park boasts an
impressive average of 82 percent over
all 23 seasons
and 88 as its average audience score
but what about the movie you ask well it
might not have been fair to include the
movie here but guess what
did not affect a darn thing those
averages are the exact same
with or without the movie nuts right i
know but not as nutty as that christmas
when morty's dad jerry finds out why his
dad wears a superman costume
in the bedroom tmi
happy human holiday dad that episode
occurred during season one which set the
high mark for rick and morty on the
tomato meter
at 96 percent man he sure says
you can run but you can't hide [ __ ]
an effort that would be matched by
season three clearly this show's report
card is a little bit better than
rick's as its overall average across all
seasons is a downy fresh
94 on the tomato meter listen to me
morty
homework is stupid the whole point is to
get less of it south park gets more
competitive with the audience score
but it's still bested by team sanchez
smith
with their 93 total average but props to
south park as their debut season was 85
percent on the audience score then it
quickly rose to a dominant
reign of 94 to 96 percent from seasons
four through nine
meanwhile rick and morty kicked off with
an incredible three-season run
but season four saw it slip all the way
down to 84
and as south park will tell you you take
the good you take the bad
no i'm being told that's that's facts of
life okay
but if your bad is super fresh you're
still doing something right
mrs garrett would approve
south park continues to muster
impressive responses from critics and
audiences
and it certainly has the tenure track
over rick and morty but for a show like
r m to open with such a strong effort
amongst a crowded field of more
adult-themed animated shows
thanks south park oh wait i guess the
simpsons already did that first
that's enough to give rick and morty the
win in round number one
and it's one to nothing in favor of the
show that sometimes stars
shrimply pibbles i had a bet with the
producer alex that i'd nail that in one
take
boom
[Music]
put your right foot forward and your
left foot back and slide around like on
a nordic track
round two ratings okay rick and morty
you may have turned some eyebrows with
that round one win
but does that come with eyeballs as in
is anyone watching your show
and if so do they also find rick's
constantly shifting green goop on his
chin as funny as i do
it never gets old you can be very
inconsiderate sometimes
the answer to at least one of those
questions is yes in fact rick and morty
is averaging 1.89 million viewers per
episode through its first four seasons
and that number has been bolstered by a
record-setting season three debut that
set a new standard on adult swim
boom big reveal i'm a pickle oh season
three has the high per episode mark at
2.51 million viewers
however season four set the low bar 1.52
million views per episode
and sure nowadays comedy central maybe
easier to find or
more accessible than cartoon network but
back in 1997 when south park debuted
different story entirely yeah old
249 on my directv wasn't so simple in
fact was directv even
a thing all i know is my family didn't
have that cable package but season one
of south park
still landed 3.36 million viewers per
episode back then
and how about season two uh we don't
have reliable data for that
or season three or four or you know it's
just going to be quicker to get to
season 11 where
our numbers return and remind us of
season one 3.3 million folks was the
average for the 11th
season of south park and the show has
seen a relatively steady downward
decline to its 22nd season
which has the low mark of 1.4 million
viewers per episode
no doubt a giant chunk of both shows
ratings loss as they get longer in the
tooth
is due to the rise of streaming giants
housing marquis shows
like the one with pickle rick or the one
where a bully unknowingly eats his
parents
tough lunch there scott tenderman
oh my god oh my god
but the good news for the rest of
colorado is staying power matters in
this round
and having 19 more seasons than rick and
morty gives
south park plenty of pudding in which to
find proof
and although season 20 of south park
only averaged 1.71 million viewers
overall
that season's debut saw the program's
highest rated episode in over a decade
do you remember it if not here try these
berries
remember berries are not the ratings
data indicates that south park has been
a consistently popular force in
entertainment for over 20 seasons that
spans
four decades and now it's time for
another fun
fact in 1997 9.1 million homes carried
comedy central
based in large part on the inaugural
success of south park that number
increased
to 50 million by 1998.
hey i love when fun facts also indicate
which way i'm leaning in any given round
fish sticks are on the house because
this one goes to south park and we're
tied
at one to
[Music]
christmas one what the hell is christmas
poo round three
characters how does one possibly begin a
character round about a show that has
bestowed upon us
four blessed seasons with infinite
protagonists antagonist
and anti-protag did your dad write this
game
sub question how does one accomplish
said task for a show packed with 23
seasons of riches
the answer is simple talk like the micro
machines guy
rick sanchez morty smith best smith
jerry smith summersmith mr poopy
butthole photography raptor mr meeseek
squanchy's carrie terry the one mower
dog mr bird person
gather buzzer field and king jellybean i
missed up the garfield a little bit but
you know what it just occurred to me
an easier way to do this might just be
rattling off a few characters i really
enjoy from each show
conveniently enough rick and morty has
rick and
gasser pizzorfield there we go okay i
like morty too
rick and morty's doc brown marty mcfly
relationship is a nice way to convince
your friends to watch the show for the
first time
and once they do they're bound to get
hooked on r m's endlessly entertaining
conflict
even rick's burps have their own
subdivision on youtube
and yes i might be more drawn to the
show because there is a tinge of hope
with rick's relentless exploring and a
dash of faith from morty's plucky
decisions to tag along
despite his near-constant reluctance
we need a vacation and here's why rick
and morty could compete with south park
in this round
we not only know who these characters
are but we just might
care about them too sure most of the
time the action flies too fast and the
jokes land too furious for us to keep
up it's not all bad though they were
spared having to see their grown son
wear a whistle
god damn thanks noob noob but part of
the draw of rick and morty
is that we're rooting for them you too
bizarro foul mouth garfield
now give me my [ __ ] enchiladas hey
rick you know
did they use bill murray for this south
park's cast of characters is as deep and
wide as the rich tradition of the denver
broncos
right off the bat it's surprisingly
randy who gets the most belly laughs out
of me
it's also hard for me to resist barb
brady and i'll yearn for the days when
chef
was chef oh did they give you an anal
probe
and his parents gave money to the loch
ness monster it still makes me giggle
and the monster bent down and said i
need about 350.
but our four boys headline the show and
with them comes
an interesting dilemma by this time we
know exactly how
cartman kyle stan and kenny will react
to any given situation
the results are usually hilarious kyle
and stan
truly hate cartman and kenny usually
hangs around for most of the episode
leaving the strength of south park not
necessarily with the characters
themselves
but of the frequently news related
action going on in any given take
cartman is very funny to me and i often
turn to the show when i need a good
laugh
but i can also acknowledge that eric is
probably a horrible influence on the
real kids watching
i wasn't saying anything about their
culture i'm just saying their city
smells like
ass i don't have any of those and i
don't blame a cartoon for the world's
problems but hearing what comes out of
his mouth time and time again
could be construed as a negative
influence for a youngling
i'm talking of course about ginger kids
oh sick
gross as i wrote that i looked up at my
tv and rick had just shot someone in the
head
so let's just all agree that these two
animated shows probably should not be
taken all that seriously
and tell your kids the same i know
everyone wants people they like to be
right that's why popular people are
[ __ ] dumb
the show is called south park for a
reason it's literally the whole damn
town
but rick and morty have gone to the ends
of the earth amongst other dimensions to
introduce us to a bevy of unique side
characters and while many of the south
park tertiary players are simply
stereotypes
every new alien we meet in rick and
morty opens a world of possibilities
it's only been four seasons but the
attachment i feel to the characters in
rick and morty
rivals out of any show i've watched much
less the one that i go to for big laughs
from four
foul mouth utes did you say utes
yeah two youths i'm surprising even
myself here but i'm going with rick and
morty in round three
according to creators dan harmon and
justin roiland the show might go
seven seasons total and while i'd lobby
for them to add on
say 30 more seasons i could quit now and
be happy with my decision
big win for the underdog now let's see
what the next round has in store
welcome to your reckoning baby
well it's official i had too much to
drink last night
round four iconic moments a celebrated
poet once authored the line
forever is composed of moments it was
either emily dickinson or bob's skaggs i
don't have the intel
i was in college look when i was in
college i was way too busy giggling at
south park to
study history or literature yes my dorm
had what mom and dad did not comedy
central
so let's start with that first moment on
the first south park short that really
got the kids talking
and the parents nervous jesus fought
santa claus it happened the spirit of
christmas only grew from there and the
show was just getting started with
manufacturing recurring memories
oh my god they killed kenny over
and over and over again and again and
again
kenny didn't die
whether it was mysterious cow
disappearances or the very festive
result of a bodily function
mr hanky the christmas poo haven't you
guys ever heard of it south park wasted
no time in letting all of us viewers
know
what this show was going to do is break
all the rules
or just ignore them entirely oh my god
what kind of television have you kids
been watching
just the news similarly rick and morty
thrusted us right smack dab in the
middle of an otherworldly adventure from
the start
then it picked up the speed season one
is littered with great horror film
homages from scary terry to the
cronenberg reality that holds up
as maybe my favorite of all the
alternate rick and morty's
that just but the horror also got real
with a very shocking encounter from king
jelly bean
it was as disturbing as it was
controversial but also served as a clear
signal the rick and morty
isn't here just for laughs and it's a
sign of the elevated esteem in which we
now hold animation
neither one of these shows is ever going
to be mistaken for kitty programs but
can they actually teach
us adults and reinforce our own moral
fibers
hmm other all-time highlights for this
rick and morty fan would be the time
rick lives a whole life in the arcade
the good night moon min song from
mortynight run
and can any nugget enthusiasts forget
the szechuan sauce incident
that inspired a global demand for that
delicious concoction
nah and now it's gone this is the only
place we're gonna be able to try it is
in my memory rick you're doing this bit
while your brain is melting okay all
right as someone who frequently checks
youtube comments at his own peril
i found personal glee in the toxic rick
and morty episode from season three
if you've ever put out a youtube vid it
will soothe your soul
you think that's funny you gotta have a
sense of humor about these things
oh wait you can't you're literally
incapable of seeing the bigger picture
and yes south park has always seemed to
have something to say about society and
the toxicity that can arise with any fan
base
but its chief job is to do so with
consistent
laughter oh wow it's the avengers that's
right
oh and honey boo boo kids come see the
green honey boo boo costume
whereas rick and morty populates its
cast with celebrity guest stars
south park prefers to poorly imitate
a-listers
and then completely humiliate them tom
cruise getting trapped in a closet
russell crowe's rampage around the world
benifer
even my beloved washington football team
franchise's owner dan snyder
was rightfully skewered in an episode
more like that trey and matt
when i named my company washington
redskins it was out of deep appreciation
for your team and your people
it's not a question of if you're
laughing at south park it's just a
question of how icky you feel
afterwards but sometimes the show just
gets flat out hysterical
kyle's dab living his fantasy of
becoming a dolphin
ranks way up there for me as does the
entire world of warcraft adventure the
boys go on
oh and anytime satan pops up i just
preemptively prepare for knee slaps
especially if it's courtesy of an al
gore summon in an attempt to stop
man bear pig
[Music]
the seasons piling up on each other do
give south park a decisive advantage in
this round but rick and morty is
certainly in step with its much older
cousin
as far as iconic moments through four
seasons south park does get the win in
this round but i want to stress
it's not just because they've had so
many more episodes worth of opportunity
to give us great memories
it's also because one of those indelible
instances involved uniting
three religious symbols into the van
halen logo
honorable mention will go to mr meeseeks
for sounding decidedly hot for teachery
with his spoken word cadence
but it is south park taking the round
and we're tied again at two to two
yeah we did it you guys
and now it's time for the wild card
round best episode
science tells us that time plus pressure
equals diamonds
and while rick and morty takes plenty of
time in their meticulous process of
crafting each and every episode
south park loves the pressure of only
having a week to crank out a new
adventure
two very different methods of production
pacing have yielded astoundingly similar
results
both shows seem to have multiple
episodes every season that earn the
right to be in the discussion
for best episode eva and that's what
this round will come down to what's the
best 22 minutes you got
the 30 minutes with commercial
interruption that encapsulates the
essence of your program
i will be selecting each show's champion
episode with some help from the old
social media machine
twitter i asked my dozens of fans and
thousands of bots
which rick and morty episode they
favored and what south park diddy is
their fave
after consulting ad nauseam with the
bluebird my own thoughts
and especially molly the wonder dog i've
arrived at this conclusion
rick and morty's episode will be the vat
of acid and south park's episode will be
super fun time
they're both great worthy of
representing their franchises
and super fun time is one of the few
south park titles i can utter without
getting cancelled
now it's my gig to analyze each
handcrafted piece of entertainment
and see who gets the w oh and if you're
keeping score at home
this round will determine the winner of
the show
and if you're not keeping score at home
it's two to two
it's really not that difficult what is
this face you're making
rick and morty have the vat of acid
episode this season four
gem is the perfect sample of rick and
morty brilliance
and not just because it references
multiple other classic episodes like
pickle rick
here the intrepid mismatched pair have a
plan that goes a bit awry
like most of their adventures rick sets
up one bat of acid that is really just a
bunch of mountain dew
and to fool any evildoers he equips it
with breathing devices and fake bones to
unleash
where it really heats up is the
challenge morty presents to his grandpa
can you make a save point that will keep
their progress in the event that they
should meet their demise
at any time oh my god
here we go it's a good idea rick it's so
genius because it's ingrained in morty's
video game generation head
and the rest of that episode plays out
like any of us would want to if we could
save our life's progress
not only does vat of acid feature the
best use of an eric clapton toon since
goodfellas
it also has one of the funniest
sequences in show history with the
extended plane crash
alive scene to include the entire run of
a relationship within something on the
level of eternal sunshine of the
spotless mind
that's pure genius a great acid vat
callback at the end puts the cherry on
top of a sundae that reminds everyone
why rick and morty is so brilliant
subversive humor
mixed with biting satire and genuine
storytelling glee
plus that game of thrones joke crushed
me
that cool thing you did without me again
the awesome thing i i guess you wanted a
dragon
unforgettable timely too you really got
in on that game of thrones fever right
at the peak
so now it's time for south park to step
up with its episode nominee
super fun time i partially picked this
one because the rick and morty side of
my brain is screaming that the playing
field needs to be leveled
so south park has so many potential
players to put into this ball game
i did make a concession my favorite
episode of south park
is actually a trilogy called imagination
land it's mind-blowingly hilarious and
amazingly intricate
but it's three episodes so i'm gonna
toss that one out of contention
along with the genius game of thrones
run they did
you know i think 30 percent of the
reason i like game of thrones so much is
because it's given us so much room for
parody
thank you dragons but super fun time is
here not just to mock lannisters but
also
old-timey theme parks with a dash of
christmas action
classics terrorists reminiscent of die
hard take over a colonial recreation
park
while the class is on a field trip there
in addition to the problem of hijackers
the boys also realize we have another
issue none of the park employees will
break
character ever even when threatened with
their life
they never break storehand you ever
heard of this fancy-schmancy
phone uh no we ain't got a phone in our
time
dude they just shot a guy in the face as
a kid who grew up partially in colonial
williamsburg
this episode really hit home for me and
i'm starting to realize why my cable
package didn't have
south park i was living in williamsburg
in the 1700s
carmen and butters managed to escape the
park before the bad guys show up
as the hand-holding pair favored the
dave and buster's like party center next
door
meanwhile burger king robbing european
nerd duels arrive
execute park employees out of sheer
frustration and are only felt by the
brilliance of
some fourth graders it's one of the best
south park episodes ever because it
peppers in topical humor but doesn't
lean on it to carry the whole show
instead it favors the tried and true
formula of cartman's rebelliousness
butter's innocence and stan and kyle's
good nature
mix in the knee-slapping guffaw inducing
commitment to their job of the park
employees and the terrorists who again
robbed a burger king and you have one
whopper of an episode
see would i you got it okay we can
is move on for the day head back to your
wagons and have a safe trip home
uh listen if anyone still wants to know
the phone is in the administration
building you dial nine to get out and
there's actually a back exit behind the
horse drops
good night everybody thanks for coming
we did it guys
both episodes are fantastic on their own
and could be an entry point for newer
fans
but south park's super fun time gets the
nod for me
only because i laughed a tiny bit harder
no disrespect to rick and morty or their
many acid vat tricks
because it can now after just four
seasons stand
toe-to-toe with any comedic show and
look it in the eye
but for today south park ain't blinking
first get the [ __ ] out of here
yes yes i did it five rounds is so
fun and takes all the anxiety away from
your dear host to make a tiebreaker
decision
south park is your winner however i
suppose i could have cronenberg this
whole show and made a sixth round about
cultural impact or
grossest bodily function gag but all the
szechuan sauce on earth dimension
c137 couldn't make up for all the good
and the bad and the ugly and
hilariousness that south park has
bestowed upon us
rick and morty's marriage of
over-the-top laughs with subtle humor is
why i can't resist the show
it's the attention to detail the
intricate thought that goes into every
frame
as evidenced by tons of tiny callbacks
only noticeable
upon dozens of re-watches luckily i'm
here to roll up my sleeves and do all
that hard work that needs getting done
south park has just busted my gut beyond
repair too many times
not just giggles or laughs or guppas but
i'm talking that rare complete
annihilation of all moral code when it
comes to
bodily functions contained during a
chuckle if you want to argue with
defensive or has crossed the line way
too many times
i'd struggle to find a counter to your
points but
my point is that the show is here to see
how far it can take the audience and how
hard it can make us laugh
in the process the creation of each
episode is such a hurried affair that
there are some missed opportunities
some ideas that feel half big but by and
large
it's the show that feels safe because it
is the antithesis
of a safe space everyone will be
lampooned by trey parker and matt stone
on their legacy show
and while the vitriol may not be dished
out in equal doses it rarely fails to
achieve its ultimate goal
shocking us into unstoppable fits of
giggling
rick and morty deserves to be celebrated
and new episodes are regarded as fans as
the precious commodities that they
should be
but south park should likewise not be
taken for granted
it has in fact done things no other
cartoon not even you the simpsons
has gotten away with south park is your
winner and i'm your host
mark ellis thanks for tuning in to
versus everyone hey youtubers make sure
you click that like button the
notification bell and comment with what
your favorite episodes of each program
are and which one you prefer
now let's all enjoy some of chef's
chocolate salty balls
not sure if i can say that okay well
stay tuned for ball fondlers
probably can't say that either you know
what pickles are delicious
good night
[Music]
[Applause]
you